find the line of best fit or mark that
there is no linear correlation so let's
see we have a bunch of data points and
we want to find a line that at least
shows the trend in the data and this one
seems a little difficult because if we
ignore these three points down here
maybe we could do a line that looks
something like this it seems like it
kind of approximates this trend although
it doesn't seem like a great trend and
if we ignored these two points right
over here we could do something like
maybe something like
that but we can't just ignore points
like that so i would say that there's
actually no good line of best fit here
so let me check my answer let's try a
couple more of these
find the line of bases well this is this
feels very similar it really feels like
there's no i mean i could do that but
i'm ignoring these two points i could do
something like
that then i'd be ignoring these points
so i'd also say no
good best fit line exists so let's try
one more
so here it looks like there's very
clearly this trend and i could try to
fit it a little bit better than it's fit
right now
so it feels like something like that
fits this trend line quite
quite well i could maybe drop this down
a little bit something like that let's
check my answer a good best find a good
best fit line exists let me check my
answer and got it right